PBS news confirms that President Biden
is expected to launch his re-election
campaign as soon as tomorrow now if he
wins America's oldest president would
stay in office until he is 86 years old
a lot of Americans say frankly they're
not comfortable with that
Ouija Zhang is at the White House was
more on that part of the story weisha
good morning to you
good morning Gail good morning to
everybody President Biden spent the
weekend at Camp David with staff and
family members who he has consulted with
for several months now about a second
term the president is expected to make
the official announcement in a campaign
video message and he has some convincing
to do according to a new NBC News poll
that shows 70 percent of Americans do
not think Mr Biden should run again
including 51 percent of Democrats now
half of those people who say he should
not enter the 2024 race cite his age as
a major reason why CBS News has also
confirmed that President Biden is
expected to choose Julie Chavez Rodrigo
to serve as campaign manager now right
now she is the director of The White
House Office of intergovernmental
Affairs that's one of the few Latinos
who hold a top position in the West Wing
people familiar with ongoing
deliberations about Biden 2024 say that
many Key Staffing and operational
decisions have yet to be locked in
including whether tomorrow is actually
the day that the president will jump
into the race but of course we will be
tracking it all Tony
we sure will be weja thank you very much